suponte que expertos en el mercado han
determinado en la relación entre el
precio de venta de un producto y el
costo de un producto y está representada
por la ecuación lineal q es igual a
menos 30 s más 800 donde q es la
cantidad vendida en un año y ese es el
precio de venta si el costo de
producción del producto es de 20 pesos
ojo si el costo de producción de
productos de 20 pesos cuál es el precio
de venta que optimiza las ganancias por
año y bueno en primer lugar sería muy
bueno saber cómo sacamos la ganancia por
año
sin embargo sacar la ganancia por año es
muy sencillo porque fíjate la ganancia
por año va a ser igual a la cantidad de
productos que nosotros vendimos es decir
q ya esto lo voy a multiplicar por el
precio de venta menos el precio o el
costo de producción a kuno voy a
multiplicar por ese que es el precio de
venta menos lo que nos cuesta producir
uno de ellos que es 20 pesos ese menos
el costo de producción y esta fórmula
tiene toda la lógica del mundo imagínate
que tú vendes no sé 2
y que a ti te costó hacer cada uno de
ellos 20 pesos mientras que tú los
vendiste a 25 pesos pues entonces 25
menos 20 me das 5 es decir por cada
producto gana 5 pesos y 5 por dos
productos venderían 10 pesos
en este caso hipotético ganaríamos 10
pesos
pero bueno además nos dan una ecuación
que relaciona la cantidad vendida con el
precio de venta es esta de aquí y por lo
tanto si yo pongo que q es igual a menos
30 es más 800 entonces me da la idea de
que yo la puedo sustituir aquí y
entonces puedo hacer cuentas con esto
sin embargo hay que tener mucho ojo con
lo que no está diciendo esta ecuación
esto está diciendo que si el precio de
venta crece entonces esto se vuelve un
número negativo más grande es decir
vamos a vender menos vamos a vender una
cantidad menor
de hecho date cuenta que si el precio de
venta es cero entonces es cuando se
venden más productos es decir lo más que
podemos vender son 800 unidades y tal
vez no sea el modelo perfecto pero ya
sabes algunos expertos
nos dirá en esta ecuación así que vamos
a utilizarla así que vamos a sustituir
esta q para ver que nos queda menos 30
es más 800 que multiplica a su vez a ese
menos 20 y hay que tener mucho cuidado
este menos 20 porque está q es esta
cantidad que estoy poniendo aquí por lo
tanto esto también tiene que estar en
paréntesis me quedaría todo esto en
paréntesis menos te interese más 800 es
esta cum que multiplica a su vez a ese
menos 20 y bueno que nos va a quedar la
multiplicar estos dos y bueno entonces
que me va a quedar lo que voy a hacer en
primer lugar es distribuir esta
multiplicación que tengo aquí estos dos
binomios los voy a distribuir y me va a
quedar menos 30 s que multiplica a ese
menos 20 ojo estoy multiplicando este
primer término por toda esta expresión
completa y después hay que multiplicar
el segundo término es decir 800 que
multiplica a su vez a ese menos 20 y
bueno ahora voy a abrir estas
multiplicaciones y que me va a quedar
menos 30 ese por eso es menos 30 ese
cuadrado menos 30 ese por menos 20 me va
a dar 3 por 26 más 600 ese
más 600 s más 600 y no olvidemos la s y
después me queda 800 por s es 800 s más
800 s
y por último 800 menos 20 es menos 16
con 30 menos mil 608 por 26 16 y son 30
123 perfecto y ahora voy a reducir
términos semejantes porque estos dos se
pueden reducir y me quedan menos 30 s
cuadrada más 600 s más de 106.400 s
menos 1600 y bueno para que estoy
sacando todo esto y ojo no olvidemos que
estas zonas ganancias que por cierto
ahora es una función que depende del
precio de venta y qué va a pasar ahora
si luego graficó precisamente esta
ganancia contra el precio de venta que
me va a quedar pues lo que quiero que te
des cuenta es que la gráfica de esto es
una parábola que abre hacia abajo así
que vamos a dibujar nuestros ejes este
va a ser nuestro eje de las abscisas y
este aquí un poco mejor ni eje de las
abscisas aquí voy a poner al precio de
venta es decir ese aquí voy a poner la
ganancia
y si te das cuenta esta función que
tenemos aquí es una parábola que donde
corta bueno no importa tanto donde corta
lo que importa es que es una parábola
que tiene como coeficiente que está al
lado de la s cuadrada un número negativo
por lo tanto como ya hemos visto es una
parábola que abre hacia abajo y bueno si
nosotros nos preguntamos cuál es el
precio de venta que optimiza las
ganancias por año realmente lo que
estamos buscando es este vértice para
esto puedes trabajar con ideas de
cálculo que me parece bastante bueno si
tienes herramientas de cálculo sin
embargo lo que quiero que te des cuenta
es que la ganancia máxima lo obtenemos
en el vértice de esta parábola porque no
hay un punto más alto que el vértice de
esta parábola así que vamos a buscarlo y
bueno entre todas las formas que hay la
forma más fácil para encontrar el
vértice es aplicar la fórmula que ya
habíamos encontrado que decía que la
coordenada en equis o bueno en este caso
en este del vértice es menos b entre 2
am así que vamos a sustituir menos 1400
entre 2 x menos 30 menos de entre 12 y
cuántos esto es menos 1400
- 60 y aquí el menos con el menos de bam
y este 0 con este 0 se va y solamente me
queda 140 entre 6 que es exactamente lo
mismo que tener voy a dividir ambos
entre 2 y me va a quedar 70 sobre 3
entonces esto es lo mismo que 70 tercios
y bueno si yo lo quisieran decimal lo
que tengo que hacer es tomar este 70
tercios y poner 3 afuera un 70 dentro y
decir 3 cabe dos veces en 7 y 3 por 2
son 67 menos 6 es uno y bajó el 0 y
después 3 cabe tres veces en 10 3 por 3
9 y sobra 1 y podría poner otro 0 y
poner un punto decimal que me quede 333
incluyes estás bien al patrón que ocurre
aquí estos 23 puntos 3 3 3 3 con 23.3
periódico es decir con una rayita encima
del 3 si lo queremos redondear al entero
mayor sería 24 pero bueno lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que el precio de
venta que optimiza nuestras ganancias en
este año es cuando nosotros vendemos a
23.3 pesos
nuestro producto si nosotros lo que
queremos
optimizar las ganancias por año de este
producto entonces tendremos que venderlo
a 23.33 pesos